so there's a
sense in which every object in the
universe has a history yeah and that is
part of the thing that is used to
describe its complexity how complicated
it is okay what is an assembly index so
the assembly index if you to take the
object apart and be super lazy about it
or minimal say what it because you know
it's like you've got a really short-term
memory so what you do is you lay all the
parts on the path and you find the
minimum um number of steps you take on
the path to add the parts together to to
to reproduce the object and that minimum
number is the assembly index is a
minimum bound and it was always my
intuition the minimum Bound in assembly
theory was really important and I only
worked out why a few weeks ago which was
kind of funny because I was just like no
this is Sacra sank I don't know why it
will come to me one day and then when I
was pushed by a bunch of
mathematicians um we we we came up with
the the correct physical explanation
which I can get to but it's the minimum
and it's really important it's the
minimum and the reason I knew the
minimum was right is because we could
measure it so almost before this paper
came out with with published papers
explain how you can measure the assembly
index of molecules okay so that's not so
trivial to figure out so when you look
at an object we can say a molecule we
can say object more generally mhm to
figure out the minimum number of steps
it takes to create that
object that doesn't seem like a trivial
thing to do so with molecules is it's
not trivial but it is possible because
what you can do and because I'm I'm a
chemist so I'm kind of like I see the
lens of the world for just chemistry um
um I break the molecule part break bonds
and if you break up if you take a
molecule and you break it all apart you
have a bunch of atoms and then you can
say okay I'm going to then Form B take
the atoms and form bonds and go up the
the chain of events to make the molecule
and that's what made me realize take a
toy example literally toy example take a
Lego object which is broken up of Lego
blocks so you could do exactly the same
thing in this case the Lego blocks are
naturally the smallest they're the atoms
in the actual composite Lego
architecture but then if you maybe take
you know um a couple of blocks and put
them together in a certain way maybe
they have a they offset in some way that
offset is on the memory you can use that
offset again with only a penalty of one
and you can then make a square triangle
and keep going and you remember those
motifs on the Chain so you can then leap
from the the start with all the Lego
blocks or atoms just laid out in front
of you and say right I'll take you you
you connect and do the least amount of
work so it's really like uh the the
smallest um um steps you can take on the
graph to make the object and so for
molecules it came relatively intuitively
and then we started to apply it to
language we've even started to apply it
to mathematical theorems but I'm so well
out of my depth but it looks like you
can take minimum set of axioms and then
start to build up kind of uh
mathematical architectures in the same
way and then the shortest path to get
there is something interesting that I
don't yet understand so what's the
computational complexity of figuring out
the shortest path in um with molecules
with language with mathematical theorems
it seems like once you have the fully
constructed Lego
Castle or whatever your favorite Lego
world is figuring out how to get there
from the building basic building blocks
isn't like a is that an EMP hard problem
it's a hard problem it's a hard problem
but actually if you look at it so the
best way to look at it for let take a
molecule so if the molecule has um 13
bonds first of all take 13 copies of the
molecule and just cut all the bonds so
take C 12 bonds and then you just put
them in order yeah and then that's how
it works so and you keep looking for
symmetry re or or copies so you can then
shorten it as you go down and that
becomes commentor quite hard um for some
natural product
molecules um it's comes very hard it's
not impossible but we're looking at the
bounds on that at the moment but as the
object gets bigger it becomes really
hard and but there that's the bad news
but the good news is there are shortcuts
and we might even be able to physically
measure the complexity without
computationally calculating it which is
kind of insane wait wait how would you
do that well in the case of molecule um
so if you shine light on a molecule
let's take an infrared the the molecule
has each of the bonds absorbs the
infrared differently in what we call the
fingerprint region and so it's a bit
like a um and because it's quantized as
well you have all these discreet kind of
absorbances and my intuition after we
realized we could cut molecules up in
Mass Spec that was the first go at this
we did it with using infrared and the
infrared gave us an even better
correlation assembly index and we used
another technique as well in addition to
infrared called NMR nuclear magnetic
resonance which tells you about the
number of different magnetic
environments in a molecule and that also
worked out so we have three techniques
which each of them independently gives
us the same or tending towards the same
assembly index for molecule that we can
calculate mathematically okay so these
are all methods of mass spectrometry
mass spec you scan a molecule it gives
you data in the form of a Mass Spectrum
and you're saying that uh the data
correlates to the assembly index yeah so
how generalizable is that shortcut first
of all to chemistry and second of all
beyond that because that seems like a
nice hack and you're extremely
knowledgeable about various as aspects
of chemistry so you can say okay it kind
of
correlates but you know the whole idea
behind assembly Theory paper and perhaps
why it's so controversial is that it
reaches
bigger it reaches for the bigger general
theory of objects in the universe yeah
I'd say so I'd agree so I've started
assembly theory of a moons with my lab
believe it or not so we take emojis yeah
pixelate them and work out the assembly
an emoji yeah and then work out how many
emojis you can make on the path of emoji
so there's the Uber emoji from which all
other emoj emo emojis emerge yeah and
then you can so you can then take a
photograph and by looking at the
shortest path on on by reproducing the
pixels to make the image you want you
can measure that so then you start to be
able to take um spatial data now there's
some problems there what is then the
definition of the object how many pixels
um how do you break it down and so we're
just learning all this right now so how
do you compute the how do you begin to
compute the assembly index of a
graphical like a set of pixels on a 2G
plane that form a thing so you would
first of all determine the resolution so
then how how what is your XY what the
number on the X and Y plane and then
look at the surface area and then you
take all your emojis and make sure
they're all looked at the same
resolution yes and then we would
basically then um do the exactly the
same thing we would do for cutting the
bonds you'd cut bits out of the Emoji on
and look at the the you'd have a bag of
pixels so um and you would then add
those pixels together to make the
overall emoji wait wait a minut but like
first of all not every
pixel's I mean this is at the core sort
of machine learning computer vision not
every pixel is that important and
there's like macro features there's
micro features and all that kind of
stuff exactly what like uh you know the
eyes appear in A lot of them the smile
appears in a lot of them so in the same
way in chemistry we assume the bond is
fundamental what we do in there here is
we assume the resolution at the scale
which we do it is fundamental and we're
just working that out and that you're
right that will change right because as
you take your lens out a bit you it will
change dramatically but it but it's just
a new way of looking at not just
compression what we do right now in
computer SCI and data one big kind of um
uh um kind of misunderstanding is
assembly theory is telling you about how
compressed the object is that's not
right it's a how much information is
required on a chain of
events